now from book people an independent
bookstore in Austin Texas physicist
Steven Weinberg his new book facing up
science and its cultural adversaries is
a collection of previously published
essays on science religion and politics
during this hour and 15 minute event mr.
Weinberg also touches on such topics as
national missile defense and the future
of theoretical physics really excited to
see so many people Steven Weinberg was
educated at Cornell Copenhagen and
Princeton and Todd Columbia Berkeley MIT
and Harvard where from 1973 to 1982 he
was Higgins professor of physics in 1982
he moved to the University of Austin and
at University of Texas at Austin and
theories career at Texas he holds the
josey regional chair of science and is a
member of the physics and astronomy
department his research has spanned a
broad range of topics in quantum field
theory elementary particle physics and
cosmology and has been honored with
numerous awards including the Nobel
Prize in Physics in 1979 the National
Medal of Science the Heineman prize in
mathematical physics the Crescent medal
of the Franklin Institute the Madison
medal of Princeton University and the
Open heimer prize he also holds honorary
doctoral degrees from a dozen
universities he is a member of the
National Academy of Science the Royal
Society of London the Academy the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
the International Astronomical Union and
the American Philosophical Society in a
recent New York Times profile James
Glanz remarked Steven Weinberg is
perhaps the most the world
most authoritative proponent of the idea
that physics is hurtling towards a final
theory a complete explanation of
nature's particles and forces that we'll
ignore as the bedrock of all science
forevermore he is also a powerful writer
of prose that can illuminate and sting
mr. Weinberg tonight's gonna be reading
a selection from facing up his new book
from Harvard University Press afterwards
we'll be taking a few questions and then
get to the book signing so thank you all
very much for coming out tonight and
please help me welcome Steven Weinberg
well thank you for having me here and
thank you all for coming
it's a lovely warm evening in Austin and
in January it's under seven days as
anyone who's going to listen to this on
c-span I hope you're hearing that the my
book's title is facing up science and
cultural adversaries the title facing up
actually has a even three meanings and
to explain it I'd like to just read from
the very beginning of the preface in
which I explain a little bit of the
motivation of the book but also
explained the title in the first year
that we were married my wife and I lived
in an attic apartment on the coast road
the strands I running along the Danish
side of the strait between Denmark and
Sweden from our living room window we
could see a little island in the Strait
needs a Swedish side our landlord told
us that the island was named then after
returning to America we learned that
then was the island were in the 1570s
the Danish astronomer Tycho Brahe he had
built his Observatory Euron Ybor without
a telescope but using giant naked eye
instruments anchored to massive
foundations bra bra hey made historic
observations of the positions in the sky
of stars and planets it was partly the
great precision of these measurements
that allowed Tico's successor Johannes
Kepler to infer that the planets move on
ellipses rather than circles a result
that later was of crucial importance to
Isaac Newton and developing his theory
of gravitation years after on a visit to
Copenhagen one summer my wife and I and
our daughter finally had a chance to
visit ven we took the ferry across the
Strait to the island and drove out in a
taxi to the site of the irani Borg all
around was farmland with nothing left of
the observatory but it's impressive
foundations above ground there was only
a granite statue of bra hay carved in
1936 by
the Danish sculptor Avari onsen a photo
of this statue appears facing the title
page of this book and here it is but you
have to buy the book to get a good view
of it as can be seen also on the cover
of the book the statue shows T Cobra hey
in a posture up appropriate to
astronomers facing up that's only part
of the reason for my choice of facing up
for the title of this collection of
essays bra hae is not one of my special
heroes he rejected the idea of
Copernicus that the earth goes round the
Sun and he was a rotten landlord the
researchers of bruh Hey
Kepler Newton and their successors have
presented us with a cold view of the
world as far as we've been able to
discover the laws of nature their
impersonal with no hint of a divine plan
or any special status for human beings
in one way or another each of the essays
in this collection struggles with the
necessity of facing up to these
discoveries they express a view point
that is rationalist reductionist realist
and devoutly secular facing up is after
all the posture opposite to that of
prayer so that explains facing up now
perhaps I should also explain a little
bit about Who I am
and what kind of thing I do as they say
when I'm at home there's an article that
I was asked to write by a magazine that
no longer exists called George some of
you may remember it it's a glossy
fashion magazine was it was founded I
believe by the late John F Kennedy jr.
and I never thought I would contribute
anything to it but they offered me a
thei per word which is the
I have been offered and their idea was
that every issue they would look back 30
years to something that had happened 30
years earlier and get one of the
eyewitnesses to describe the event
particularly things that were important
and that writers life and in 1997
somehow or other I can't imagine how
they learned that the work for which I'm
best known was done in 1967 so they
asked me to contribute an article and I
had my doubts about it but finally my
Puritan instincts were suppressed by
that nice fee and and so I wrote this
article which I think turned out in fact
to be the best statement I've ever made
of the kind of work I do what it's like
to be the kind of physicist I am the
only thing that's a little inauthentic
about this reading is that when the
article appeared the opposite page was a
perfume ad for Liz Claiborne perfume and
when you read the article in the
magazine you've got this wonderful musky
smell and Harvard Press decided not to
reproduce that effect this article is
called the red Camaro on October 15th
1764 Edward Gibbon conceived the idea of
writing the history of the decline and
fall of the Roman Empire while he was
listening to barefoot monks singing
Vespers in the ruins of the Roman
capital I wish I could say I worked in
settings that glamorous I got the idea
for my best-known work while I was
driving my red Camaro in Cambridge
Massachusetts on my way to my office in
the physics department at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology I
was feeling strung out I had taken a
leave of absence from my regular
professorship at Berkeley a year earlier
so that my wife could study at Harvard
Law School we had just gone through the
trauma of moving from one rented house
in Cambridge to another and with my wife
in law school I had taken over the
responsibility of getting our daughter
to nursery school playgrounds and all
that more to the point I was also stuck
in my work as a theoretical physicist
like other theorists I worked with just
pencil and paper trying to make simple
explanations of complicated phenomena we
live it we leave it to the experimental
physicist decide whether our theories
actually describe the real world it was
this opportunity to explain something
about nature by noodling around with
mathematical ideas that drew me into
theoretical physics in the first place
for the previous two years I had made
progress in understanding what
physicists called the strong
interactions the forces that hold
particles together inside atomic nuclei
some of my calculations had even been
confirmed by experiments but now these
ideas seem to be leading to nonsense the
new theories of the strong interactions
I have been playing with that autumn
implied that one of the particles of
high-energy nuclear physics should have
no mass at all but this particle was
known to be actually quite heavy making
predictions that are already known to be
wrong is no way to get ahead in the
physics game often when you're faced
with the contradiction like this it does
no good to sit at your desk doing
calculations you just go round and round
in circles what sometimes does help is
to let the problem cook on your brains
back burner while you sit on a park
bench and what you're watching your
daughter play in a sandbox
after this problem had been cooking in
my mind for a few weeks
suddenly on my way to MIT on October 2nd
1967 as far as I can remember I realized
that there was nothing wrong with the
sort of theory on which I've been
working I had the right answer but I had
been work
the wrong problem why don't you break
that the mathematics I've been playing
with had nothing to do with the strong
interactions but it gave a beautiful
description of a different kind of force
known as the weak interaction this is
the force that's responsible among other
things for the first step in the chain
of nuclear reactions that produces the
heat of the Sun there were
inconsistencies in all previous theories
of this force but suddenly I saw how
they couldn't be solved and I realized
that the massless particle in this
theory that had given me so much trouble
had nothing at all to do with the heavy
particles that feel the strong
interaction it was the photon the
particle of which light is composed
that's responsible for electric and
magnetic forces and then indeed does
have zero mass I realized that what I
had cooked up was an approach not just
to understanding the weak interactions
but to unifying the theories of the weak
and electromagnetic forces and to what
has since come to be called the
electroweak theory this is just the sort
of thing physicists love to see several
things that appear different as various
aspects of one underlying phenomenon
unifying the weak and electromagnetic
forces might not have applications in
medicine or technology let's be frank it
won't have applications in medicine or
technology but if successful it would be
one more step in a centuries-old process
of showing that nature is governed by
simple rational laws somehow I got
safely to my office and started to work
out the details of the theory where
before I had been going around in
circles now everything was easy
two weeks later I mailed a short article
on the electroweak theory to Physical
Review Letters the journal most widely
read by American physicists the theory
was proved to be mathematically
consistent in 1971 some new effects that
had been predicted by the theory were
detected experimentally in 1973 and by
nineteen
viii it was clear that measurements of
these effects agreed precisely with the
theory in 1979 I received the Nobel
Prize in Physics along with Sheldon
Glashow and Abdus Salam who had done
independent work on the electroweak
theory I've since learned that the paper
I wrote in October 1967 has become the
most cited article in the history of
elementary particle physics I kept my
red Camaro until it was totaled by one
too many Massachusetts winters but it
never again took me so far well I think
this time for another reading I tried in
this book not to avoid controversy but
to express my my view of things and in
fact I I enjoyed getting certain well
feeling that I was stirring up the
reading the reader many of these
articles were based on talks I had given
in which I had tried to stir up the
audience sometimes even more than I had
wanted to this article was not based on
a talk it's called confronting O'Brien I
when I was a little boy I used to listen
to a program that I barely could
understand on the radio we didn't have
television shows how old I am called
information please the moderator of the
program was a man named Clifton Fadiman
who seemed to know everything about
everything some of you are nodding
you've heard of Clifton Fadiman well I
was I was just amazed let's see when was
that I was amazed in 1988 when I
received a letter from Clifton Fadiman
inviting me to contribute an essay to a
book he was putting together called
living philosophies which was a
collection of personal philosophies of
various random people and I was so
flattered by this voice from the radio
land of my childhood coming and reaching
me that of course I said yes
and the fee for this was not very high
but it was so flattering and so I I
wrote a little essay about
my personal philosophy should give me
for having such a thing and I'd like to
read the closing part of it I I talk a
lot about things that I don't believe in
and then I come and say finally although
I write here about what we should decide
what we ought to believe it's not so
clear to what extent we can decide what
to believe for instance it's there
resistible to believe in our own
existence and most of us can't help
believing in the existence of the world
around us even under the urgings and the
most skeptical philosophers nevertheless
it seems to me that we can exert some
control over our standards of belief and
then we ought to try to follow something
like the methods of science but it's not
so easy and perhaps not so common
throughout history people that seem to
have been willing to accept Authority in
judging matters of fact the effects of
the authority of the living organized in
governments and sects or the authority
of the Dead expressed in tradition and
sacred writings I don't mean that
they've bowed to Authority just in what
they say they believe which could be set
down to a reasonable prudence but also
in what they do believe George Orwell's
novel 1984 gives a brilliant description
of how this can work as hero Winston
Smith had written in his diary that
freedom is the freedom to say that two
plus two makes for the Inquisitor
O'Brien accepts this as a challenge
under torture Smith is easily persuaded
to say that 2+2 makes five but that's
not what O'Brien is after as the pain
increases Smith becomes so eager to stop
his torture that he manages to convince
himself for a moment that 2+2 could be 5
O'Brien is satisfied and the torture
ends for a while authority doesn't
usually operate with such efficiency but
even when it threatens us with smaller
pains over a lifetime these can have
impressive effects on what we believe
today the hold of authority on our
beliefs seemed to be slipping at least
in Morden
parts of the world we've seen places
where it isn't slipping unfortunately
however we needn't rely on outside
authority as a source of pain we all
have to face the prospects of our own
deaths and the deaths of those we love
there is pain enough for us each to be
our own O'Brien's I can recognize the
existence of these sources of belief but
I don't really understand them when the
second triumvirate declared officially
in 442 BC that Julius Caesar was a God I
can well understand that prudent
citizens would pay their respects to a
statue but could they really believe
that he had become divine and if they
didn't believe it what was the point of
it all today with the decline of
authority one often hears people explain
that they believe in this or that
because it makes them better or happier
well it's easy to see how one's beliefs
could arise from a desire to be good or
happy but if one knows that this is the
source of one's beliefs
how can one continue to believe I
suspect that belief is not the simple
matter discussed by epistemologists but
a more complicated emotion like love but
many find it satisfactory to believe and
not believe the same thing at the same
time but I think one ought at least to
try to resist this temptation I wouldn't
try to justify the scientific method
where it applies by appeals to reason or
experience all such arguments are
hopelessly circular well all that I can
offer on my own feelings that there is a
moral imperative when it comes to
deciding what to believe
deciding matters of fact to decide them
in this way the way exemplified by
science that there is something ignoble
in doing otherwise rereading the last
few paragraphs I'm bothered as you may
be bothered here by their tone of
self-satisfaction I don't know to what
extent my beliefs are under my control
and to the extent that they are why
should I follow the cold rules of
science rather than believe in what
would help
make me good or happy and if I can't
adjust my beliefs to suit myself why
should that be a source of pride after
all I don't take any pride in the fact
that I can't consciously control my
heartbeat or my knee kick reflex still
there it is
I am proud that I will not or cannot
believe in what I do not believe so
after this long preamble what do I
believe all my experience as a physicist
leads me to believe that there is order
in the universe here and there amid the
general messiness of ordinary life we
see water appearing spontaneously as in
a crystal or a rainbow there was also
the Grand order of the expansion of the
whole universe and more intricate the
adaptive orderliness of living things
evolved over hundreds of millions of
years of natural selection and
underlying all these is an order in the
logical structure of the universe we can
ask why crystals or rainbows or DNA are
the way they are and receive an answer
in terms of the physics of atoms and
radiation and if we ask why these
physical principles are the way they are
we get an answer in terms of a quantum
field theory of particles that are
called quarks leptons and gauge bosons
as we proceed down this chain of
explanation the principle seem to become
simpler and more unified we explain more
and more with less and less input I
think though I'm not sure that at the
end of this process we'll find a few
general principles laws of nature of
great simplicity and beauty at any rate
I've devoted my own life to work in
elementary particles and physics in
elementary particle physics and
cosmology because I think that at this
moment in history that's the best way to
make progress
totally toward these final laws of
nature it would be wonderful if in
uncovering the principles underlying the
universe we had discovered ourselves if
we had found that a grand cosmic drama
was going on in which human beings play
a starring role we haven't
nothing that scientists have discovered
suggests to me that human beings have
any special place in the laws of physics
or in the initial conditions of the
universe if this is true then we're not
going to be able to look to science for
any help in deciding what we ought to
value at the end of my earlier book the
first three minutes I allowed myself to
remark that the more the universe seems
comprehensible the more it also seems
pointless this one sentence got me into
more trouble with readers than anything
else I've ever written but all I meant
was that if we search in the discoveries
of science for some point to our lives
we won't find it this doesn't mean that
we can't find things that give point to
our lives if science can't provide us
with values and neither can it
invalidate them my own values for form
something of a disorganized hodgepodge
high on the list are loving one another
enjoying beauty both natural and
man-made and learning about the universe
scientifically I don't see much point in
trying to be systematic about such
things because even if I did organize my
values into a coherent scheme like
utilitarianism which you know tries to
maximize the total fun of happiness in
the world or the distributive justice of
John Rawls which directs us to seek out
the most unhappy person in the world and
devote all the resources of the world to
increase that person's happiness until
we find someone else who then becomes
more unhappy and so even if I did
organize my values into a coherent
system and then found that some
imperative of the system contradicted my
intuitive value judgments as is in fact
the case for these two examples I would
then just scrap my system this isn't to
say that moral systems can never be
worthwhile they have some value in
convincing other people but at bottom in
our value postulates we're not
responding to some cosmic imperative but
just as we're rather inventing values
for ourselves as we go along it seems to
me that we're in the position of a
company of players who have by chance
found their way into a great theater
outside the city streets are dark don't
worry I'm gonna be finished in a minute
outside the city streets are dark and
lifeless but in the theater the lights
are on the air is warm and the walls are
wonderfully decorated however no scripts
are found so the players begin to
improvise a little psychological drama a
little poetry whatever comes to mind
some even set themselves to explain the
stage machinery the players don't forget
that they're just amusing themselves and
they will have to return to the darkness
outside the theatre but while on the
stage they do their best to give a good
performance I suppose that this is a
rather melancholy view of human life but
melancholy is one of the distinctive
creations of our species and not without
its own constellations I would say to
add to that that I think another thing
that I find a distinctive creation of
our species which allows us to face up
to and cold and impersonal universe is
humor I try in the book into the limit
extent I can to bring a little bit of
humor in the humor that I find missing
in works like the Bible of the Koran I
find so wonderfully present in in
Shakespeare or trollop or Jane Austen I
think is one of the great values that we
we have created and I look at the world
really grateful for the opportunities
for humour the spectacle of so many
kinds of nonsense in the world for all
the cultural relativists post modernists
multi Clergerie multiculturalists clergy
men of all sects socialists Republicans
it a great sense of humor Wells up and
it makes one grateful to the cook for
being allowed to witness all this thank
you very much
well I'm happy to take questions and
it's conceivable just barely but not
everyone here agrees with everything I
say yes sir
I'm sure you're familiar with David I
had a couple of two questions one is
David Deutsch his book the fabric of
reality sort of touches on a possibility
that quantum mechanics and and gravity
and all those forces and once we finally
understand that consciousness and
evolution or all those things will come
together at that level and I was
wondering what you thought about that
well David Deutsch has thought more
deeply about the philosophy of quantum
mechanics and I have I mean this is this
is a peculiar thing in the history of
physics that we the branch of physics
that we most seriously believe is truth
without any approximation quantum
mechanics which we use to understand
everything we can understand the nature
still has peculiarities in his
philosophical interpretation which we
haven't come to grips with but I don't
believe that the solution it lies in any
kind of fusion of human affairs human
mentality for example with the
fundamental laws of physics someone once
accused me in a letter responding to an
article I had written in the New York
Review of Books of the article is
reproduced in this book and said that I
was trying to drive the gap between
human affairs and the laws of nature and
I responded in my letter that I thought
that was a much needed gap
and I think the greatest progress in
science has been to learn for example
that Aristotle was wrong in his
conflation of value judgments say
nobility with the laws of nature there
are noble elements like fire and ignoble
ones like earth value judgment simply
don't apply that that's an elementary
example of course and one which we've
long since historically but passed but
we have learned not to look at the
fundamental principles of nature in
human terms it's a painful lesson but
one we've had to learn just continued
the Camaro do you recommend another
automotive contemplate theoretical
physics no but I think watching you know
if you have a daughter of ten years old
or so watching her play in the sandbox
is a very good move 10 you know that's a
little bit too late yes sir you know
wait for the microphone there's boom mic
for me years ago I read a quote from a
physicist and I'm gonna purify
paraphrase that it might even have been
you and it was something to the effect
that I'm coming to realize that nothing
exists unless there is a consciousness
that exists to view it and I'm wondering
what would be your observation on that
thought that actually fits in very well
with the previous question this is the
kind of view that grew up in the early
days of quantum mechanics in the earth
in the early 1930s quantum mechanics
tells you how to calculate the
probabilities of various things for
example if you have a particle in a
certain kind of field of force and you
want to know where is the particle there
isn't a definite answer but you can
calculate what is the probability
getting different answers when you
measure the position of the particle but
until you measure the position of a
particle it doesn't have a definite
position and this is led to an enormous
amount of nonsense some of which is due
to physicists like the point of your
clothing Oh like I don't know who it is
but perhaps maybe Niels Bohr or Werner
Heisenberg and unfortunately the level
of nonsense this decreased since then
particle does have something whether you
measure it or not it has what's called a
wave function the wave function is a
mathematical object but it's out there
it exists in the world and when you
measure the position the wave function
changes in such a way that it has a
definite position and the position it
has depends on accidents that can't be
controlled it doesn't have a definite
position until you measure it it doesn't
have a definite speed until you measure
it but it has a definite wave function
and the wave function cranks along it
changes in a deterministic way the
spirit of physics really didn't change
that much with quantum mechanics
although at first it seems so strange
that even very very intelligent people
were led to make unwise remarks about it
I don't think that quantum mechanics
provides a basis for epistemological
relativism the kind of view that says
nothing exists until I observe it
particles don't have momentum until you
force them to have momentum or you could
force them to have position you can't do
both at the same time but there is
always an objective reality out there
and and there is a wavefunction and it's
and it just goes on and doesn't matter
whether you're measuring it or not and
it was there before human beings
appeared on the scene yes
I heard your wonderful interview today
on ket that was excellent
yeah weird way you briefly discussed
some political issues and one of the
things that I took away from that was
that you were advocating sort of a
redistributed political philosophy and
greatly increasing public spending on
certain core issues and I was wondering
how you reconcile a what's were a very
anti-authoritarian philosophy with
regard to say the church and yet more of
an acquiescence to to the overt physical
coercion of an authoritarian State
that's a very good question and it is a
serious problem how can you manage that
if I can restate the problem how can you
have governments apply things that can
only be supplied by government I mean
even the most conservative economists
would agree that only government can
supply national defense and police
protection and there are other things
that we need government to supply
whether it's health care for the
indigent or drug rehabilitation for drug
addicts who can't afford it otherwise
there's also public school education for
everyone all sorts of things for which
we we need government to supply public
goods and yet how do we avoid or talk
the government controlling our lives we
have found in America a wonderful way of
doing that it's called the charitable
deduction we have it we have at least we
had a system of fairly steep income
taxes combined with very generous
charitable deductions so that unlike
countries in Europe in America our
operas and museums and many of our
hospitals and many of our best
universities not all of them but many of
them are entirely supported by private
donations and are out of aside the
control of the government they're being
funded in a sense by government because
a lot of those contributions are
motivated by the fact that then you can
deduct it on your income tax
unfortunately we seem to be moving in
exactly the opposite direction from this
this is a peculiarly American phenomenon
remember going to the Opera in La Scala
in Milan and asking how much the
citizens of Milan contributed to the
Opera and being told nothing at all it's
entirely a government enterprise we have
so much a better system here our operas
or symphonies they're all privately run
the government has does not have that
dead hand on them we used to have a
fairly steep progressive income tax
which allowed but but nevertheless which
allowed people to make full deductions
for any charitable contribution they
made with the government playing no role
in determining which was a good
charitable contribution of which wasn't
and we seem to be giving that out and
it's conservative economists who want to
get away from that and have a level
income tax where everyone pays the same
rate the poor band as well as the rich
and but also make it increasingly
difficult to deduct for charitable
contributions I think that's terrible
and well I also think quite apart from
the mechanism by which we fund things
that the greatest needs of our society
are for public goods for things that
can't be supplied by the free market
whether it's education health care
homeland defence police protection these
are the things that really determine the
quality of our lives not whether we can
afford a car that gets five miles a
gallon that doesn't add much to the
quality of our life a flat-screen
digital television well who really cares
I'm a hopeless tax-and-spend liberal and
I what you can see I'm not running for
public office
I think many of the things in our
society are terribly underfunded and one
of the things that I think that's
underfunded is the University of Texas
at Austin but I could go on and on about
that is there another question yes sir
I'd like to see if I perceived your
personal attitude accurately when you
spoke of a quarterly universe I think
your personal view is unrelated to
punishment or torture as in the book you
reference but instead because it's
something that makes you feel good
I think the feel-good approach is our
human nature and for example the
statement or idea that there exists a
moral imperative for us to engage in the
scientific approach and coming to our
own personal reality that assumes that
the universe is in fact amoral which
again I think is a feel-good approach no
I don't agree with that I don't think
morrow you know your moral postulates I
don't think they can ever be explained I
think it's wrong to murder people I
think it's wrong to hold people in
slavery I can't prove any of those
things I think it's wrong to believe
things because they make you happy I
mean for example belief in an afterlife
boy would make me happy to believe in an
afterlife and feel that I wouldn't say
goodbye forever to my wife and daughter
when I die boy that'd be marvelous but I
don't believe in and I think it's
somewhat ignoble to believe in things
just because they make you happy but I
don't that doesn't follow from anything
there's no there's no reasoning that
goes into that it's a gut feeling which
has to be at the bottom of all value
judgments why is it wrong not to go
around killing people I don't know it
just is I think all attempts to found
moral
postulates on some kind of scientific or
logical or mathematical judgments are
hopelessly doomed we just have to have
them and try to find other people that
we can join together who have similar
ones and make a society that we want to
live in I don't think we can do any
better than that yes sir as physics
hurtles towards the the final theory I'm
this is fascinating little slowly it
hurts but but let's assume that we have
enough time that it progresses it
continues does this mean that we have to
ultimately abandon the scientific method
oh no we arrive at a final theory which
is not which we can't verify
experimentally you know so we're altom
utley going to have to accept a theory
rather than some verifiable I mean in
the first place I want to emphasize that
when I talk about a final theory I wrote
a book called dreams of a final theory
I'm I use the word final theory as an
alternative to what is popularly called
a theory of everything because it will
only be final in a certain limited sense
it will be as I talked about in that
article facing O'Brien it will be
terminating the chain of wise why this
well because of this principle well why
is that principle true well that's
because of another principle I think
we'll come to the end of a chain but
they'll still be an infinite number of
things that we don't understand
I mean developing a final theory of the
kind that I'm talking about will not
help us to understand human thought it
will not even help us to understand
turbulent fluid flow which is we already
understand the laws of nature well
enough for that purpose it's just too
complicated for us to get our minds
around but the other thing I wanted to
emphasize in answering your question
it's true that as we go deeper and
deeper into studying nature we get
further and further away from everyday
not only from everyday life but now
we're
further away from things that can be
directly studied in the laboratory we
can create elementary particles but we
don't see them we just see tracks that
are produced little chains of bubbles or
sparks in a chamber and we infer that
was a particle that went through we
never see the particles and it gets even
worse as you go further into physics
you'll begin to talk about structures
like strings that are so tiny that it's
hard to imagine that human beings will
ever be able to create the individual
strings and see that they're not just
point particles but that doesn't mean
that it's not going to be an
experimental science the test of a
theory is whether it makes enough
predictions of in a critical way so that
you're forced to believe it we have a
theory now called the standard model
which accounts for essentially
everything in nature except for
gravitation but it has a number of
arbitrary features there are about
eighteen numbers in the standard model
that have to be put in by hand just to
make the theory agree with experiment
they're numbers like the masses of the
different quarks and the charges of
different particles we don't know why
they have the values they have we just
put them in and then the theory agrees
with experiment if we developed a final
theory let's say a theory of strings
much too small to be studied in the
laboratory we would know if it was
correct according to whether or not it
explained those eighteen numbers if a
young graduate student tomorrow and is
perfectly possible developed a string
theory that in a natural and satisfying
way allowed you to do calculations and
calculated that the mass of the electron
was this and the mass of the top cork
was this we would believe that theory it
would be well-founded experimentally we
never do all the experiments that you
might dream of to test the theory you
just have to do enough to convince
yourself that the theory is right right
now we have a theory of the strong force
the force that holds quarks together
inside the atomic nucleus with a
beautiful named quantum chromodynamics
that theory has been tested only in
certain very
in context particularly it's been tested
and experiments at very high energies
where you for example collide an
electron and antielectron together at
very high energy and you see what comes
out and the theory works works
beautifully we can't so far use the
theory to calculate very much about what
goes on inside the atomic nucleus the
old problem of nuclear forces hasn't
been solved the problem of calculating
the mass of the proton the nucleus of
the simplest atom
hasn't been solved we may never solve it
these problems are really hard and yet
we believe the theory is had enough
success that's the way things go
physics will remain an experimental
science even if you can't do experiments
on the particular structures which are
most fundamental in the theory and to
take another example the quark itself
will never be observed in isolation
that's a that's a prediction of quantum
chromodynamics yet quarks are the
building blocks of the particles inside
the atomic nucleus we don't have much
doubt about it the theory works that's
the way you you trust things you learn
to trust things because the theory works
not because it makes not because you've
tested every possible prediction of the
theory so I stand up for the
respectability of string theory as a
part of the historic tradition of
physics as an experimental science
although it's I'm afraid it's not
getting there very fast but it's still
our best hope for the future another
question yes sir
you've talked about a final theory and
then I've read speculation that there
are there's perhaps the possibility that
as we continue to probe particles with
higher and higher energies we might just
continue to find more and more levels of
structure I know that's a nightmare for
particle physicists is it actually
possible is it contradicted by physical
theories and based on what you said
about wanting a final theory would you
find that philosophically repugnant or
just another aspect to the universe I
would find in certainly disappointing I
would like to think that there is a
final theory and that human beings are
capable of discovering it it is the
possibility you mentioned is always
there when I visited China in 1978 with
my family the Chinese physicist said we
don't believe that in a final theory
because Mao has said that there is
always more and more structures as you
go to smaller and spell things well it
may be true although I don't know how
Mao could know it's possible I hope it
isn't true I think I think it isn't true
because we have seen a growing
simplicity in the way we understand
nature the present standard model of
elementary particles is incredibly
simple compared to what I had to learn
as a graduate student which was a whole
cookbook of odd miscellaneous facts
about particles it was like becoming a
zoologist but things are really much
simpler now and although I can imagine
unbounded complexity I can't imagine
unbounded simplicity things can open so
that's my reason for thinking and not
merely hoping that there will be a final
theory there are other possibilities too
that human beings may not be smart
enough to understand it the present
generation of string theorists use
higher mathematics at a level that my
generation was not trained for and that
really has me in awe and I don't know
how many more generations of
in the mastery of higher mathematics
we're going to have to go through but
eventually we may run out of steam I
don't think that's going to happen
either because I you Minh beings can
join their intellects through language
and there's also a possibility which is
the most serious one of all and that is
that just as the wonderful flowering of
Hellenistic science that took place from
the death of Alexander the Great
until the takeover the Greek world by
Rome was a period of tremendous
scientific progress science in the sense
that we would use it today
understanding buoyancy understanding the
motions of projectiles old so
understanding the size of the earth and
that came to an end with the absorption
of the Greek world by Rome and I don't
know why it had to come to an end it
didn't quite I mean there was a certain
amount of science continued especially
in the Greek half of the Roman Empire
but then it really did come to an end
with the fall of the Roman Empire ours
may come to an end if you know there are
a lot of forces in the world that are
hostile to science I have a I had a dear
friend he's dead now abdus salaam who i
shared the nobel prize with who was a
devout muslim although the muslims
regarded him as a heretic he wasn't even
allowed to return to his home country in
pakistan and he used to complain
bitterly about the hostility to science
among is Lama countries who were willing
to accept technology engineering but did
not want to introduce the scientific
perspective into their universities a
lot of people in the world find an
antipathy to science and well in our
country you don't find that very much
but you find a lot of people who are not
willing to pay for scientific research
through their taught through their taxes
unless they can see a clear application
in terms of a cure for cancer or
something like that so we may simply run
out of out of support from society
but then it will be taken up again in
another age one expects yes another
question yes back there
you sure some of what you have done in
trying to make some unifying sense of
the field of physics you studied in some
of your your beliefs do you have any
sense beyond yourself of whether there
is a story a bigger human story that
satisfies some of the the things that
some of the great faith traditions have
provided for humankind in past eras of a
new story that humankind can grasp on to
and and provide a unifying kind of
impetus for people to come together gee
I sure hope not it seems to me that
tremendous harm has done been done down
through the ages by these stories that
people tell stories about a God speaking
out of a burning bush or stories about
Jesus being taken out of the tomb or
stories about Mohammed making a night
journey to Jerusalem I think the whole
sorry procession of fairytales not only
is a failure of the human intellect to
face face up thank you yeah to face up
to things as they are
but also has has created such enormous
harm religion has justified slavery it's
justified holy wars and I'm speaking now
of all religions at the present time the
fiercest most intransigent religious
belief is found in the Islamic world and
I don't think one can say that this is
merely a corruption of religion I don't
think it's it's there's something
inappropriate for George Bush or any
less than err to say Osama bin Laden is
not true Islamic you know who is he is
to say that he's not
this these people who flew airplanes
into the World Trade Center were not
making believe about their religion I
mean they must have believed that they
were going to paradise otherwise it was
a very bad career move and in the past
you know the Christendom did horrible
things in the name of religion and the
Crusades we would be so much better off
without it
and so I hope we don't look for stories
I hope we face up to what is really I
think a tragic situation that human
beings are in and which can only be made
worse by by denying it it's a tragic
situation in which there is no objective
basis for moral judgments but we still
have to make them there is no cosmic
drama going on but we still have to act
as if we have a certain nobility there
isn't even any scientific justification
for science itself but we still do it
and we still think it's worth doing and
we're all just the result of hundreds of
millions of years of breeding and eating
resulting in a somewhat random way and
us not a result of any cosmic plan but
we still have to love each other and
care about each other it is a tragedy
that we we are in and it would be better
not to have stories that give us the
illusion that it is not that our
position is not a tragedy
no I don't think so
well I mean I don't think well maybe I
misunderstood what you meant by a story
I think there's nothing particularly
grand about human evolution it could
have gone in completely different ways
we were not called for by any kind of
evolutionary imperative if a comet
hadn't hit the earth when was it 65
million years ago of the mammals might
not have succeeded in displacing the
dinosaurs I'm Way out of my specialty
I'm not sure whether any of this is
right but I'm sure that there been
countless accidents that led to us and
there's nothing particularly wonderful
from the point of view of objective
science about us as some biologists
could point out the really successful
organisms on earth or the bacteria
they've lasted much longer and they
outweigh in total biomass the human race
nevertheless we have to face that rather
dismal story and go on acting as if we
have some value and it's a value we give
ourselves it's a difficult lesson and I
don't expect to found any religion this
message and I'm not going to call from
contributions from the faithful but it's
a it's a lesson that people will learn I
hope and eventually when everyone learns
this lesson perhaps the world will be a
little bit more peaceful and gentle and
people won't go around flying jet liners
into buildings yes I really enjoyed your
talk today
the radio oh and the poem that you
and just can't think what it was and I
haven't been looking old book say yes
yes and then they say plays of music and
what you had to say about that that was
just really not just a mistake
it was poignant and I you know I didn't
get depressed
the thing is that you you say a lot of
things that people who are depending on
stories and certain types of belief
systems find very threatening and and it
is depressing for them and it can be it
can really threaten ones basis of having
hope and you need some some kind of
basis and I really enjoyed what you said
today well thank you I certainly don't
mean to be depressing as I said earlier
I think humor is one of the great
consolations in all of this and and all
the other things we value the person who
interviewed me on the radio today sprung
Dover Beach on me and a poem I I love
them that he apparently likes very much
- and it it describes a rather
melancholy picture of the sea of faith
that was once girdled the world is now
withdrawing and we heal we hear it's
dull withdrawing sound and he talked
from the dark whom the dark shingles of
the world
it's a very dreary picture and then
after doing all the had he said I'll
love let us be true to one another which
is the answer to the to the more dismal
part the more dismal view of the human
condition and then he goes back and says
for the world which lies before is so
beautiful in sanu has neither help has
neither this nor that and our help for
pain but we're on as on a Darkling plain
we're ignorant armies clashed by night I
think that the poem encapsulates what
I'm trying to say that we have to have
both we have to be able to face up to
the tragic position we're in and at the
same time I love let us be true to one
another
well I'm happy to go on the I don't know
how what much take the camera people who
have but yes sir I'm wondering what you
see as the relationship between science
and reality that is the you talked about
the laws of nature and theories and as I
understand it the theories are models of
the behavior of nature and these
theories of these models have been
changed with time they have evolved I
mean is there any necessity or reality
particularly when you talk about a final
theory that sort of sounds like it but
you qualified it about it you know only
in a very limited sense I mean what is
the relation what do you see is the
relationship between the theories of
physics or science and the behavior that
it studies the reality you are asking a
very deep question what is the
relationship of all these theoretical
constructs which are I mean clearly
Maxwell developed Maxwell's equations
it's name is on them what does it have
to do with the underlying reality and I
don't know the answer
philosophers have studied this for
centuries and have not really provided a
satisfactory answer but I would say this
that if you're comfortable in your
everyday life with the fact that the
rocks on the ground are real and you
don't worry too much about what is the
relation between your perception of them
and the the the objective reality of the
rocks then to the same extent that you
don't worry about that you shouldn't
worry about it when you come to science
because the for us at least for
scientists who live with them the laws
of nature as you get to live with them
have the same kind of reality that the
rocks on the ground have this is not
intended to mean that I've solved the
like ontological problem of what is what
you mean by reality I just mean that the
naive realism I think this is what
philosophers actually call it naive
realism that we all use in our everyday
life I'm you when you drive home tonight
will not worry about the reality of the
light being red or green you will accept
it that's red or green and stop or go or
at least I hope so
that kind of pragmatic attitude I think
is appropriate also in science because I
don't see any sharp philosophical
dividing line between common sense
judgments we make in everyday life and
science we are base what we do our
reasoning and observation the same way
you do in everyday life our theories
have a reality in the sense that rocks
have when we if we don't discover them
someone else will if we get it wrong we
will learn about it by a process which
is somewhat akin to stubbing your toe on
a rock that you didn't realize was in
this place rather than some other place
we're capable of making mistakes about
them they don't seem to be culturally
bound someone from Japan will see this
rocks the same way you do a woman will
see the rocks the same way a man does we
see that in science also the kind of
science that Sun doesn't depend on
whether you're from Japan or America
whether you're a man or a woman so in
all those ways that kind of toughness of
being outside there not being a creation
of your own imagination that rocks have
scientific theories have and it doesn't
answer your question really because
there's a deeper still what do you
really mean by them being real and I
don't know the answer to that and learn
not to worry about it
yes I don't buy now I'm probably calling
them the same people again is there
could could you put your hand down if I
have already called on you because I'd
like to call on people I haven't called
on before okay in the corner there yes
do you think are most useful to
emphasize for training world-class
theoretical physicists oh my it's very
hard I mean most what the question was
how do you train theoretical physicists
with difficulty generally speaking they
train themselves I've had a I've had a
handful of students that in my life that
have gone on and done really good things
in physics and I can't recall that I
ever taught them anything some of them
in fact did a PhD thesis and let me know
at the last minute what it was gonna be
about obviously there is training that
goes on at some point more and more one
needs fancy mathematics higher
mathematics I would emphasize that and
it's I would also emphasize just trying
to learn as much as possible not just I
once had a young undergraduate come into
my office when I was a professor at MIT
and I asked him what kind of thing he
was thinking of doing in physics he said
I want to work on the theory of
homogeneous cosmologies I thought this
is incredibly stupid for an
undergraduate to have such a precise
idea of what he wanted to study and in
fact it was a very narrow field which
was mathematically overdone by the time
he even said his remark I want to learn
an awful lot of different branches of
physics I wish I could say that
philosophy was a help it isn't and I
wouldn't bother too much with it
it's it's somewhat of a mystery why
philosophy of science is not more useful
to science somewhere in here I quote a
remark that it's like ornithology isn't
really very useful to birds but I would
try to get the broadest possible
education and physics in the deepest
possible education mathematics but I
guess the main advice I would give a
young person beginning to study for any
field of sciences not to wait to be
taught things by your professors but go
out and learn them yourself because your
professors judging from all my
experience including of myself are not
that good at teaching and you do best by
learning things yourself
yes question yeah I wanted a second what
you said about the importance of humor
and we've been reminded of that on PBS
lately with this special and Mark Twain
and he's of course this huge humorous
but he faced tragedy and depression in
his own life and that's how he dealt
with it with humor but more mundane
level daughter son and their several
fortunes anyway
I had a question about your view and
what you see in your opinion on our
government's renew all this missile
defense Oh in the next the question was
why do I think about the renewal of the
government's interest in missile defense
in the next issue of the New York Review
of Books the one that will arrive I
don't know if it's sold in this store
yes it is good because it's not sold and
Barnes and Noble but maybe it is I'm in
the next issue of the New York Review of
Books there will be a long article by me
about missile defense in which I go over
the history of it and then I face some
of the issues and Mike let me just tell
you the conclusion of it which answers
your question I her at the very end of
my article though we're going all sorts
of issues for and against missile
defense I think I was pretty fair I said
I I refer to the fact that in physics we
make a distinction between pure physics
and applied physics pure physics is
physics for its own sake without just to
learn more about nature applied physics
has some goal that's important to
society and both are important both are
valuable things to do but not everything
that's pure is worth doing and with the
Bush administration's national missile
defense program what we have looks very
much like an example of pure missile
defense that is it's a missile it's a
defense system which is not likely to
give us protection even against the
threat for which is designed that threat
is implausible and it weakens our
security in many other ways so that my
conclusion is that this is pure missile
defense missile defense pursued for its
own sake rather than for any application
it might have in defending our country
missile offense well I fortunately we
are cutting back on a missile offense I
I think one of the reasons I'm against
missile defense is because it's likely
we should try to get down
to hundreds or dozens rather than
thousands of warheads on ready-alert and
we should try to get the Russians down
also and prevent the Chinese from
building up from 20 weapons to several
hundred and missile defense stands in
the way of that I think as long as we
have a missile defense system under
development the Russians are not going
to get rid of their Merv's they're not
going to take their missiles off ready
alert they're not going to reduce below
a certain level they are reducing
because they have to for economic
reasons but they're not going to cut
down to the level that we really need to
safeguard our country our country is
really in serious danger from an
accidental or an unauthorized launch of
the thousands of warheads that the
Russians have and it's not inconceivable
because their early warning capacities
are getting worse and worse I don't
think that President Putin is planning
an attack on the United States but at
some future time when there's a crisis
in relations between the United States
and Russia when they have different
leaders when they're getting in one
misleading information from the early
warning radars as already has happened a
few times who knows this is a much more
serious danger than anything else that
faces our country it's the only thing
that could destroy our country beyond
our capacity to recover it's not
something that missile defense can help
us at all with because in fact the
missile defense system is specifically
advertised as not being able to to
eliminate the Soviet missile threat
and by developing missile defenses
rather than many other things we could
do like helping the Russians to get rid
of their weapons-grade uranium and
plutonium we are weakening our security
rather than strengthening it I'm very
serious about it I think our country is
in serious danger it's a much greater
danger from this than from any dream of
terrorism and we're not acting
responsibly enough to protect ourselves
from it and missile defense is not the
protection we need yes yes II had this
question you sort of take the expanding
universe and sort of run it backwards in
time then why wasn't there no was there
whoa why wasn't the universe ever
localized such that it couldn't escape
its own gravity or what prevented the
universe from him Cody backing on his
self into a single black hole well the
universe may in the future implode back
on itself it's all the question of
whether or not the expansion has reached
escape velocity and this is a matter of
measuring the speed at which galaxies
are rushing away from us and measuring
the amount of matter in the universe to
decide how much gravitational force
there is pulling things back you know if
you throw a rock up from the surface of
the earth of it if you throw it up which
is not likely at more than seven miles a
second it doesn't fall back it escapes
and goes on forever and on the other
hand if you throw it up at less than
seven miles a second the gravity of the
earth brings it back we don't know
whether the universe will fall back or
not but right now the evidence seems to
be that not only will it not fall back
into a Big Crunch but it will in fact
the expansion seems to be accelerating
which is terribly exciting result of
just the last few years if you look back
in the past
well things didn't
mater accelerated away from other matter
or at least it moved away from other
matter because it had some initial
velocity what caused the initial moment
of the Big Bang we don't know we don't
even know whether there was an initial
moment if there was it was some kind of
singularity which our present physical
theories are incapable of understanding
it may be that the universe is
infinitely old and that what we think of
as the universe this big expanding
mishegoss that we're in is just one part
of a much larger universe with many big
bangs going off here and there this is
where I start waving and and that this
will happen again and again time without
end there's lots of things we we don't
know we understand the history of the
expansion of the universe very well I
think from a time when the universe was
about a second old if that has meaning
to the present we can follow the course
of the origin of atomic nuclei the
recombination of hydrogen into neutral
atoms the first development of
structures in the universe all of this
is pretty well understood but what
happened at the beginning with the
biggest obstacle is well of course we
can't see back to the beginning but it's
not only that we don't have physical
theories that are capable of describing
what happens at sufficiently high
temperatures and densities that's one of
the things that we hope will come out of
a final theory the capability of
calculating what happens to matter under
extraordinary circumstances and that may
answer these questions whether there was
a beginning of what the universe is
infinitely old right now it's just a bet
manat something about which one can have
an opinion on philosophical grounds it's
a question of ordinary science and
it'll have to be answered by observation
and theory by the ordinary methods of
science it isn't philosophically absurd
to say the universe had a finite
beginning in time thirteen or fourteen
billion years ago and it isn't
philosophically absurd to say the
universe is infinitely old both ideas
are possible and we just don't know
which is right yes well I think we're
probably running out of steam which is
just as well because I'm running out of
steam thank you very much Steven
Weinberg was the 1979 Nobel laureate in
physics facing up science and its
cultural adversaries is published by
Harvard University